hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to lord of the Isle the game
that was made in a game jab which
features a few themes it was like
elderly selfishness and clumsy so I soft
screenshots of the game and it looked
adorable and I have been want to play
these games before so I'm gonna click
furiously to start I am the lord of the
Isle none shall pass
I must block the passerby until they go
back from whence they came to move arrow
keys are WASD or hold down the left
mouse button
oh you daughter bull old man man let's
go ah what are you doing in my aisle
young man how do you do you think you're
doing get out oh my I'll wear the
cranberries grandma's wear you also
grammar Zoo ah
wait where's going on you seem young
whippersnapper I love it yeah that's
right yeah
get out of my territory this is the
silliest game I've ever seen is this all
I do really that's awesome oh man really
this is all I do I just stand here in
this aisle and who are these faceless
ghost trying to pass through my lines I
shall use my power to smite them slice
them oh my goodness Wow hahaha that's
amazing how's that old man even doing
this this isn't powerful wizard for an
old man you know what I mean the Lord is
only one Lord of the aisle sure this way
No oh they're getting restless I better
stay on my toes whippersnappers her go
back no lady you're not gonna get by
babe where Wow
witness the full power this oh man oh my
goodness oh I remember I cast walls to
keep everyone out
the defense's this is the most
ridiculous thing I've ever done
am i using beer bottles is different my
underwear older than you
ah I don't know if you guys can read the
text off the bottom but it's a little
arias oh my god this game is charming
and adorable simplistic but kind of
Awesome
can't you see I'm standing here haha hey
we're going back from my lonely one
lordy I'll hello share cranberry guy
rivers Evers
okay let's cash yeah oh I don't know if
I'm like it's the weirdest thing it's so
simple I didn't expect much out of it it
was highly rated game on gamejolt but my
goodness this is a lot of fun and I know
if it should be all this horse EU passes
will come to talk my weary bones looks
like they have forgotten youth and
costly buy me even though you're right
in front of my face and I totally saw
you anyway they're becoming too much for
the old brittle bones where you shall
not pass alright tell you about passing
you shall not do it good stop bumping me
no lady in white em listen there's a
song written about you I remember a long
time ago
well now we're gonna oh no oh no oh I'm
so sorry how could I not how could I not
all hopes dreams and friends of your
younger days eventually pass you by
alas you cannot stop the passage of time
my old friend that's so sad ah no I just
started the beginning and I want to only
I want to get this I want I am very
interested in play this game was oddly
fun I'm gonna give it another go
right honey welcome to Walmart I love
little young lady they'll come back
never garden God will fit perfectly I'll
make sure all my hi hi sneak it up on me
ha ha ha ok I'm back on wave 4 you know
it's it it's really interesting because
it's games like these that remind me
that like indie games are literally
anything this game should not exist by
the laws set out by bigger companies or
whatever have you whoever decides what
games are worthy of whatever it doesn't
matter this came is awesome
and I can't believe someone like just
came up with this on the fly
programmed it in a game jam god damn
this is getting tough Wow Wow I can't
believe like someone would do that but
and at the same time I like applauded it
because this game is just ridiculous and
awesome ridiculous and awesome
ah you shall not pass not Ryan yep yeah
don't ask me how I'm lightning
out of my butt it's not an easy trick
only years of experience with hands as
you know a rock creepy you're creepy
don't be creepy about Bieber
I guess I whoa the walls are shambles
I'll need some reinforcements who can I
count on by myself I must keep fighting
keep forever forget huh how did I cut
myself hi man
yes hello grass there's a final wave the
ride away oh my goodness oh my goodness
oh my god this is gonna get really
frickin hard I know that yeah young
whippersnappers yeah oh my goodness oh
no don't push him this way Oh God oh
this bad this is bad this is bad this is
bad this is bad this is bad
oh my god oh my god no no I can't lose
it I won't down again no no no no
Oh God it was hard I didn't know how to
control my little guys all the hopes
dreams and friends of your younger days
eventually pass you by it's so sad but
that was the theme of the game jam this
game was adorable and awesome and I
challenge you guys to beat the last
level I challenge you
links in the description the game is
totally free like many of these in the
games are there totally free to play
played it's adorable it's awesome
it shows some meaning that any games are
still there to be something special for
like no other purpose then have an idea
come to life like it's totally cool I
know there's not a lot of deep meaning
to be taken from this game but even so
the fact that it exists alone is saying
enough that it's cool it's legitimately
awesome so thank you everybody so much
for watching check out my awesome games
playlist there are great many indie gems
in there that I played over the days you
know few years that I've been on YouTube
that are just phenomenal examples of why
indie games are the future like they
really are individual ideas are going to
be what's the what everyone's gonna be
playing because frankly I'm tired of
triple-a titles like they just don't do
it for me their cash cows their money
grabbers whereas the ideas and the cool
stories that I've experienced have
mostly come out of indie games anyway
thank you guys so much for watching
click the annotations obviously have for
more videos from me and as always I will
see you in the next video bye bye
pristiq up soon phone chica